und in emsdetten begrüße ich die
bundestagsabgeordnete und
gesundheitsexpertin der linken kathrin
vogler guten tag vor fogler
hallo schönen guten tag heute mittag
wollen die gesundheitsminister der
länder die ergebnisse ihrer zweitägigen
beratungen verkünden was erwarten sie
sich von dieser runde was wäre aus ihrer
sicht das mindeste
also ich gehe davon aus und das hat bodo
ramelow ja gerade auch gesagt dass die
bundesländer darauf bestehen werden dass
es einen gesetzlichen rahmen gibt den
bundesgesetzlichen rahmen den der
bundestag beschließt auf der dessen
grundlage sie weiter in ihren ländern
angepasste maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der
pandemie und zum bevölkerungsschutz
vornehmen können und das ja auch völlig
nachvollziehbar und wir werden als linke
natürlich darauf großen wert legen dass
diese maßnahmen auch sozial ausgewogen
sind und dass sie auch an die wurzeln
der probleme gehen weil die lage in den
krankenhäusern ist ja nicht nur pandemie
bedingt sondern die ist ja schon viele
viele jahre so wie sie ist und eine
überlastung des gesundheitswesens wie
wir sie im winter pandemie noch
verstärkt erleben erleben ja die dort
beschäftigten schon seit vielen vielen
jahren in einem punkt sind sich die
meisten landesregierungen einig lockdown
sie im letzten jahr schulschließungen
ausgangssperren all das soll es nicht
mehr geben bleiben damit also maßnahmen
wie kontakt beschränkungen obergrenzen
2g 3g da geht jetzt jedes bundesland
wieder seinen eigenen weg kommen ist das
segen oder fluch
daher so ein flickenteppich ist
natürlich eine herausforderung
insbesondere für die menschen die
beispielsweise von einem bundesland zum
anderen pendeln weil sie in dem einen
arbeiten in dem anderen hohen und es ist
natürlich auch immer geeignet dass man
dann dass eine bundesland gegen das
andere ausspielt das heißt man muss den
rahmen schaffen in dem eben auch
bestimmte
maßnahmen so geregelt sind das eben für
die bundesländer einfach ist die dann zu
ergreifen ich will aber noch mal was
sagen zur amtierenden geschäftsführenden
bundesregierung also wenn ich jetzt ein
zeugnis schreiben müsste für herren
sparen würde ich wahrscheinlich
reinschreiben er hat sich stets bemüht
was in der sprache von personalchefs ist
aber so richtig hat das nicht
hingekriegt also wir haben jetzt den
zweiten pandemie sommer hinter uns und
wir müssen wieder feststellen dass
nichts passiert ist also dass die
bundesregierung es versäumt hat
gemeinsam auch mit den landesregierungen
eine gesetzliche regelung auf den weg zu
bringen die diese pandemische notlage
entbehrlich macht und auf die dauer das
leben die einstellung mit dem corona
virus ja ja der ist ja nicht einfach weg
der verschwindet nicht einfach man kann
ja auch nicht absagen das eben
ordentlich regelt das hauptproblem ist
ja in der tat die zu geringe impfquote
von jetzt knapp 70 prozent aber man muss
sagen vor vogel auch in ihren reihen
gibt es stimmen die die sicherheit der
zugelassenen impfstoffe in frage stellen
sahra wagenknecht spricht von einem
genetischen code den weg bekommen sie
haben sich von ihrer fraktionskollegin
distanziert aber der schaden auch für
die glaubwürdigkeit der linken gerade in
der korona der debatte ist auch nicht so
schnell wieder gut zu machen
die linke ist eine partei die sich in
der gesundheitspolitik immer für
wissenschaftliche evidenz basierte
lösungen einsetzt also wenn wir darüber
reden mit welcher versorgung welche
versorgung patientinnen und patienten
brauchen dann bestehen wir immer darauf
dass es gute studien gibt und dass die
sicherheit der patientinnen und
patienten ganz oben steht und ich kann
an der stelle nur sagen geben stoffe die
wir haben die sind sicher sie sind
wirksam und ich kann jedem nur raten mit
ihrem hausarzt ihr haus als sind zu
besprechen dass sie sich impfen lassen
können denn es ganz klar mit der delta
variante gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
immun zu werden das eine ist sich impfen
zu lassen das andere ist die krankheit
durch zu machen und das durchmachen der
krankheit es hat sehr viel gravierendere
gesundheitsfolgen und zwar in allen
altersklassen
ersteren ländern europas zum beispiel da
gibt es ja sogar schon die impfpflicht
zumindest mal am arbeitsplatz oder auch
für die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
in pflegeeinrichtungen während man bei
uns noch darüber streitet ob man
wenigstens pflegekräfte zum ticks
verdonnern darf laut ard
deutschlandtrend der kam gestern abend
raus befürworten 57 prozent der
bundesbürger eine allgemeine corona
impfpflicht hat die politik der angst
vor der eigenen courage oder doch eher
vorjahr im skeptischen wählern die man
nicht verbringen will
also ich glaube man muss diese debatte
führen aber muss sie auch rational
führen aus vielen ländern in denen es
eine impfpflicht gibt wissen wir dass
dort die impfquoten also ich habe mir
jetzt bei anderen
infektionserkrankungen nicht etwa höher
sind sondern niedriger als bei uns also
ich habe mal eine einer gesetzlichen
pflicht weg halt auch immer so was wie
trotz und widerstand
ich würde den anderen weg gehen ich
finde bin dafür dass wir das impfen so
einfach und so bequem wie möglich machen
für die menschen für viele ist es auch
eine große hürde einen termin in einer
arztpraxis zu vereinbaren das heißt wir
brauchen weiterhin auf suchen.de
impfangebot und ich glaube was wir auch
brauchen in vorbereitung auf den auf den
wintern das war ein schwerer fehler der
bundesregierung
die flächendeckenden test infrastruktur
einzustellen die kostenlosen tests zu
beenden denn beispielsweise für für die
altenheime oder auch wenn jemand privat
jemanden besucht der beispielsweise
chemotherapie macht will ich mich doch
auch dann testen lassen wenn ich geimpft
bin und wenn ich dafür bezahlen muss ist
das eine würde die viele leute nicht
überwinden können ich glaube diese
debatte wird auch in den nächsten tag
nochmal an fahrt aufnehmen frau vogler
ich danke ihnen für das gespräch und
einen schönen tag nach emsdetten
schön groß nach berlin